we take the phone calls of a man who has
seen quite a bit in his time covering
Houston sports since the mid-70s from
the Houston Chronicle John mlan joining
us the day after Bill O'Brien is Let Go
by the Texans how are you John I'm doing
great Rich how are you I'm hanging in
there I'm hanging in there always great
to hear your voice and you're the first
person we reach uh we reach towards and
want to join us when something big
happens in Houston and this certainly
suffices and checks that box what
happened John what happened you in the
bills last year the Texans beat the
bills in the wild card game went up on
Kansas City 24-0 in the second quarter
in the divisional game and then got
steamrolled and they've been terrible
ever since they're the biggest
disappointment in the NFL at' 04 coming
off a loss to winless Minnesota and the
owner Cal mcir had seen enough because
they knew the team was going in the
wrong direction so um all right but why
do it I mean why not think that the guy
that has won uh four out of the six
division championships in the AFC South
could turn it around why why Romeo
crenell why that if he number one if he
thought Bill O'Brien could turn it
around he would have kept him they knew
they were going to lose the first three
games although they didn't expect to
lose I'm I take that back they wanted to
win the first three they played at
Kansas city hosted Baltimore and played
at Pittsburgh and they looked Terri
terrible no consistency on either side
of the ball in any of those games
quarter here half there so here comes
Minnesota giving up 440 yards a game
terrible against the Run Texans couldn't
beat them Texans were last and rushing
last against the Run only team that
hasn't throw hasn't forced to turn over
something had to give and in terms of
something had to give uh you know it
seems to me that they took the car keys
oh way too late John I mean the the
DeAndre Hopkins deal just makes makes
this look like uh you could have seen it
coming uh certainly with David Johnson
and and not having any draft choices
next year already and starting at ow
and4 is is is any of his General
managing part of the reason why he lost
his gig yesterday John well bill was in
charge of personnel for the last two
years even though he was on given the
title of J general manager after last
season but he had made all the Personnel
decisions 22 of the 53 he brought in
including seven starters in the uh in
the Minnesota game so uh I believe
because none of us here thought they
would be in his predicament I didn't see
light at the end of the tunnel I thought
they would probably lose to Jacksonville
because there's a lot of problems on
both sides of the ball and uh Cal McNair
said he didn't like to do it they like
Bill O'Brien but you had to put aside
personal uh your personal relationship
when you got to make a business decision
and that's what they made was there a
struggle within the building power
struggle with the Jackie Easter be who
was brought in and we know that led to
the previous general manager being fired
and then a power void that was filled by
Bill O'Brien for the last couple of
years is that is that something that was
going down too John Bill O'Brien Bill
O'Brien at F sale Personnel decisions he
and Easter be had disagreements every
coach and and well he's not a GM he's
Executive Vice President of football Ops
had disagreements but did usually I was
ask if they had a falling out if you
have a falling out to me you don't work
together that's the way it was with Bill
O'Brien and Rick Smith in this case they
worked together they had disagreements
they had arguments everybody has an
argument with Bill who has a bad temper
and explosive personality but Bill
O'Brien had final say on every big
decision nobody else and Cal McNair
signed off because he believes you rgm
you give him the money to do what he
needs to do and then you get out of the
way and if it and if it doesn't work you
get rid of it it wasn't working this
year they got rid of it what's the one
thing if Bill o' BR could wave a wand do
you think he would change today other
than just he go back to the Kansas City
game in which they just choked that 240
lead he would not call the fake puno
fourth down at on his 31 yd line which
backfired led to an easy touchdown it
was the worst call of his career well I
mean and then the fake punt that that uh
that that uh succeeded it as well that
gave a short field to to to Kansas City
I mean if you're seeing that fourth down
call that he thought they had made it a
first down and then when he found out it
was fourth decided just you know In the
Heat of the Moment to kick it and that
led to you know the comeback I guess
that that sparked the to come back
pouring gasoline on the fire was the the
fake punt that that came after that but
these are all X's and O's decisions I'm
I'm saying a roster I mean this team is
0 and4 with no uh picks in the top two
rounds next year and um you know Watson
is under contract which is terrific I I
just keep returning to DeAndre Hopkins
and I know that we live in a fantasy
football world and we look at football
players and fantasy terms and same thing
with trades I that one is still the
ultimate head scratcher if you've got a
guy in Watson that you know you're going
to pay and you know he's your guy of the
future and you know you've got somebody
of DeAndre Hopkins status at the age of
27 how in the world do you do what he
did how does that happen how does how
does the own sign that contract with
three years left on it they would have
redone it with two and I'll say this
about DeAndre he was here when he got
smoked by the Chiefs in the playoffs
when they got beat 417 at Baltimore in
regular season but yes he's the goto
receiver and I don't think if he was
here they would be any different than ow
and Thor because they're so bad on
defense and can't stop anybody but he
may have made the scores closer but I
don't think he would have made a
difference in an 04 record John mlan of
the Houston Chronicle here on the Rich
Eisen show so who's obviously it's not
going to be Romeo corell's gig moving
forward I don't imagine even if he does
uh finish the season above 500 from here
on out with The Talented players that
they do have what do you think they do
who do you think they go to well first
of all you're right corell's 73 he's not
win the rest of the games he's not going
to be the head coach next year they
won't say I talked to Cal McNair he says
you know we got it one of the reasons we
did it now it gives us a lot of time to
put together a list of people we want to
interview I believe it'll be an
offensive background coach it'll be
somebody who's worked as a as an
offensive coordinator and quarterback
coach with a quarterback with a skill
set of DeShawn Watson to me the primary
candidate should be Kansas City
offensive coordinator Eric benemy and I
would have Greg Roman close behind at
Baltimore Greg was fired here in 2005 in
the Dom Capers Purge he had coached two
positions and but the enemy would be at
the stop of my list let me just spe may
I wildly speculate John which is very
which is it's it's irresponsible of me
but I'm going to wildly speculate I have
no idea if it's feasible or not or if it
makes any sense or not but I I mean if
you want to make your quarterback
comfortable and you want to have
somebody who knows how to coordinate and
plan for Deshawn Watson what are the
odds of taking every dollar on planet
Earth and calling up Clemson and asking
dbos swinny if he wants to do something
like this what about that idea fans here
always bringing up already bringing up
dbo Lincoln Riley if dbo Sweeny was
interested in coming to the NFL and he
called K McNair's agent and said he's
interested of course he would listen to
him if Lincoln Riley did that Lincoln
Riley uh turned down down Jerry Jones
and the Cowboys now Lincoln Riley wasn't
0 and2 at the time maybe he changed his
tune but it's going to be a coach who
has a history I believe of working with
successful quarterbacks who have the
same skills as Watson and I'm sure if
dbba was interested they'd be all over
him but I've never seen any interest in
what in him in the NFL no matter what
kind of money he was offered no I know
that and maybe part of the reason why is
he's never been offered to be connected
with DeShawn and then obviously we from
the outside start connecting dots I I
don't know if Andrew Luck would ever
wanted to be reconnected with Jim
Harbaugh you know what I'm saying I I'm
assuming the
relationship uh was hunky dory um um and
that's why I'm I'm supposing it what
about the Watson obrian relationship
what let me ask you this how do you know
Deb I want want to be working with
Trevor
Lawrence you know what um that means he
would go to New York one of the two New
York teams you know know well this is
this is a good job Rich because the
owners pay a lot of money they are very
patient with the head coach they stay
out of it they're they know what's going
on but they stay out of it I think Bill
Bill had a good relationship with Watson
up until this season Watson had been
really successful he's thrown four
touchdown passes in the last two games
he's had a great first half in
Pittsburgh great second half against
Minnesota but he hasn't put together a
full great game like he did so often
last year but he had no issues with
O'Brien at least based on everything he
said publicly all right John Before I
Let You Go what's what's the scoop with
the Rockets what are you hearing about
them moving forward here boy I know they
were interested in Doc Rivers and he
took that job before sunset in
Philadelphia now I have no idea what
they're going to do and let me ask you a
question Rich how about those
Astros by the way I'll tell you what uh
John uh everybody here in Los Angeles
loves having and the Astros there in
Dodger Stadium they just love it they
can't get enough of it John they can't
get enough of the Astros tear up Dodger
Stadium people forget how well they hit
in Dodger Stadium when they cheated to
get that uh world series title in
2017 I guess they took those trash can
lids and and buzzers with them to
Dodgers Stadium in the World Series well
I guess I tell I don't know John if they
tear up Dodgers Stadium the Dodgers
would just like them to take all the
trash and and put it in the can please
um you know wouldn't it be something the
Astros went it Dodger Stadium the
Dodgers come here to go to the World
Series and lose in Houston how
embarrassing would that
be love you John mlan thanks for the
call you take care of yourself you be
well you take care too rich thank you
very much as always you bet that's John
mlan hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here